es sind reviere mit eigenen gesetzen mit
checkpoints und barrieren als
außenstehende in die siedlungen im
norden von marcel hineinzugehen sei zu
unsicher warnt man uns
es braucht mehrere anläufe bis nasser
einer der jungs einwilligt uns in sein
viertel zu bringen
wir befinden uns hier in den city
bestens bekannt aus den medien für
kriminalität drogen und morde
er selbst habe nie gedealt bekräftigt
massa er wollte profisportler werden
doch dann hatte er einen unfall
nun ist er arbeitslos unser weg führt in
diese geschlossene grundschule heute den
verfall und vandalismus überlassen
früher ein ort zum gemeinsamen lernen
und spielen
natürlich wurden dafür andere schulen
gebaut aber weiter weg von hier man kann
dort kaum mit öffentlichen
verkehrsmitteln hinkommen
die meisten die hier wohnen fühlen sich
im stich gelassen
bekommen wir zuhören verein leben
behörden haben sich zurückgezogen es
fehlt an jobs an vorbildern die kinder
wachsen in einem milieu in dem
drogenhandel normalität ist die
preisliste für cannabis und co hängt
offen aus
hier werden die drogen verkauft
das ist wie bei mcdonald's man bestellt
aus dem auto heraus und wird im auto
bedient man muss also noch nicht einmal
aussteigen um drogen zu bekommen
allein fürs schmiere stehen bekommt man
150 euro am tag ein lukrativer job für
minderjährige konflikte mit der polizei
nehmen sie dafür in kauf doch mit der
kriminalität wächst auch die gewalt die
gefahr für alle im viertel
[Musik]
wut und verzweiflung treiben sie auf die
straße rajan noras sohn wurde gerade mal
14 jahre alt die polizei geht davon aus
dass er opfer einer schießerei unter
drogenbanden wurde getötet von den
kugeln einer kalaschnikow als er mit
freunden vor seiner haustür stand
wenn die kleinen noch nicht mal draußen
mit ihren freunden ein sandwich essen
können da steht es wirklich schlimm um
uns und die sicherheit in marseille
seinen namen haben sie auf ihre t shirts
gedruckt familie freunde nachbarn wollen
dass alle von seinem schicksal erfahren
uns erzählen sie von der angst die ihren
alltag beherrscht es müsse endlich etwas
geschehen
wir sind nicht alle dealer nur weil wir
in den vierteln wohnen unsere kinder
werden von verbrechern getötet und wir
müssen dafür auch noch lösen
wir werden hier im stich gelassen
stattdessen wird sich nur um die viertel
im zentrum der stadt gekümmert dort wo
das geld ist
die metropole am mittelmeer hat sich
rund um ihren hafen herausgeputzt hier
bekommen nur wenige mit wie es in den
hochhaussiedlungen im norden der stadt
zugeht ergebnis jahrelang verfehlte
sozialpolitik die auch die polizei
täglich zu spüren bekommt die fühlt sich
oft ohnmächtig fordert härtere maßnahmen
von justiz und politik
ganz klar die polizei als die kontrolle
über einen teil dieser viertel verloren
wir sind dort weiter auf streik es gibt
feste nahm wirklich jeden tag aber wir
als polizei sind nicht mehr in der lage
das problem der unsicherheit dort zu
lassen
die drogenbosse führen einen brutalen
kampf um die vorherrschaft in den
quartieren es geht um macht vor allem um
geld
[Applaus]
ich will ihnen ein beispiel geben in
marseille gibt es 156 plätze an den
drogen verkauft werden einen tagesumsatz
zwischen 10.000 und 60.000 euro
mit einem milliarden-hilfsprogramm will
frankreichs präsident gegen steuern
ortsterminen wassers nassers vierte sein
besuch wird unweigerlich wie ein
wahlkampfauftritt den jungs aus dem
viertel ist das egal sie nutzen ihre
chance reden klartext
wir werden nicht mehr als mitbürger
wahrgenommen sondern sind nur noch die
aus basars nur weil sie jetzt hier sind
schauen alle auf uns ansonsten würden
wir gar nicht gesehen
ihren plan müssen sie mit uns
ausarbeiten die politiker zusammen mit
uns den vereinen den opferfamilien denn
wir haben mit unseren erfahrungen viel
wichtiges beizutragen
amin hat eine traurige geschichte sein
bruder wurde getötet verbrannt in einem
auto eine rechnung wurde beglichen wie
es in marseille heißt nun hat amin einen
verein gegründet sie alle hier haben
angehörige im drogenkrieg verloren
niemand kann sagen mir passiert schon
nichts es kann jeden treffen
ihr leid hat sie zusammengebracht sie
wollen gemeinsam einfluss auf die
politik nehmen
wir sind kleine leute wir können nichts
ändern wie nora schon sagte bei den
wahlen gehen wir unsere stimme denen die
uns repräsentieren sollen und nichts
geschieht das muss sich endlich ändern
früher gab es mehr angebote für die
jugendlichen
marcel brauche keine kurzfristigen
lösungen sondern einen plan mehr
sicherheit in den vierteln und
gleichermaßen bildungschancen und
perspektiven für jugendliche
die jugendlichen haben gelernt sich
selbst zu organisieren
ich möchte nicht sagen dass sie
unschuldig sind sie sind verantwortlich
für ihr handeln dafür dass sie die len
aber sie sind auch opfer eines systems
das sie vergessen hat
immerhin habe der besuch des präsidenten
den norden von marseille mehr in den
fokus gerückt meint nasa ist jedoch
skeptisch ob es was bringt
aber ich will es hoffen hier ist der
staatschef der einzige staatschef der
einen fuß in unser viertel gesetzt hat
das ist doch schon mal ein versprechen
für ihn selbst gibt es nur ein ziel raus
besseres dafür würde er jeden legalen
job annehmen sein traum ist es aber
schauspieler zu werden
wir haben hier so viel erlebt es gibt so
viele talente in unserer city wie
überall in marseille in frankreich in
der welt und das möchte ich zeigen unser
können
es sind geschichten verpasster chancen
geschichten über armut und oft auch
gewalt die uns die menschen hier
erzählen ihnen einen ausweg zu bieten
eine mammut aufgabe für marseille allein
kaum zu bewältigen
[Musik]